aujourd'hui on a fermé les frontières il
va bien falloir aborder et qu'on puisse
voyager et puisse rentrer et sortir du
pays mais à un moment donné surtout
éradiquer la colline avec moment il
réalise et la colline vous posez ces
questions pour les autres épidémies ou
jamais et ça te défoncer adoré mais moi
j'ai voté si on attendait bien retourner
maladie aux côtés des maladies qu'on
dise par le sud et par une fée qu'avant
son chéri longtemps vous monsieur s'est
parlé on la met à tomber monsieur c'est
effectivement il existe d'autres
épidémies
ça vous a échappé non parce que à un
moment donné on a l'impression que la
découpe
l'épidémie a on découvre la notion des
piles et vous savez que certains pays on
est beau là vous savez que certains
pêcheurs ont la malaria
vous savez que certains pays menait vers
des virus beaucoup plus dangereux que la
copie puisque sa seule à avoir échappé
au bon sens là donc on va tous se calmer
cinq minutes le coup
aquatre le patron post helvétique
j'ai pas répondre à une problématique
dont tout cela est faux départ vous
raconter n'importe quoi le postulat il
faut des mois mais enfin si vous aimez
ça m'agace à un moment donné sur le plan
du droit qu'on vienne en permanence me
rappelais conneries sur les frontières
et machin arrêté d'employer des tableaux
des vidéos vous savez quand même que là
on rigole d'un truc c'est la toile et on
rigole de truc qui s'appelle les droits
de l'homme ouais c'est lesquelles des
gens sont morts quand même docteur
chauve cyril la tuberculose maladie
respiratoire transmissibles et je peux
vous assurer que mon service en voir
encore beaucoup de tuberculose est ce
qu'on demande aux gens vous êtes
tuberculeux avait fait un test comme
quoi vous n'êtes pas tuberculeux ils
peuvent aller dans les restaurants
il ya un moment je voulais la notion de
risque réel existe alors pour rassurer
simplement pour rassurer
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on s'excite en
a tous envie d'aller au restaurant aussi
pour assurer on sait si vous voulez que
il va y avoir une immunité collective
qui va se faire avec la vaccination
c'est que les gens combien de
pourcentage de la population soit 60 70
pour sa saga qui mais on sait que ça
n'existait pas voilà je peux les aspects
nous faire un cours de gym et
infectiologues ce que je veux dire c'est
que entre la vaccination les gens qui
ont été infectés vous avoir une certaine
immunité collective et ça va et le virus
va beaucoup moins circuler et au bout
d'un moment je voulais parce qu'il y
aura une immunité général on va voir
quand on a quatre hot coronavirus qui
tous les ans un des des rhumes
c'est pas très grave donc aujourd'hui on
a très très peur parce que c'est
effectivement cette maladie peut être
grave
on n'a pas encore tous les moyens pour
la faire venir se dit il faut un
passeport vaccinale pour visiter le
restaurant au cinéma